this is what I don't know if it works or
not oh and the worst part is it him by
myself I have no one to help with this
wait let me see if I can recall all the
lessons that hannah has taught me oh
sweet lord how does it happen it's not
as funny what memories not here to
commiserate over the fact that I don't
know if it's working or not Oh gross
okay oh sorry I look from up there the
case of the gross in my mouth happening
right now ok channel trailer this is
where we change this change trailer and
then I can add it right I add that and
what's save what's the video specs may
not appear to some views because it's
blocked in some countries are these oh
my god this is where it all falls apart
okay oh yeah me this is tweet at me this
is happening for you uh those are my
whole body gets filled with heat because
I don't know oh it's working okay all
right I think it's working from what can
you hear me is the other question okay
yeah yeah it's happening okay give me
now a moment because I'm really bad at
multitasking to just social media this
and make sure that we're all aware that
this is happening right now for all of
us we're live yeah and also i'm just
going to announce everything i'm doing
out loud so
that we don't feel like there's empty
space there's the other great thing I
haven't done a live show with you guys
by myself in a really long time so this
is going to be a lot of me going a
little kind of fill empty space from the
awkward next the next building to it
revived come chat or not kinda give you
guys this options feet tweeted yeah okay
oh yeah this is very exciting okay yay
hello everyone and welcome to UM welcome
to Sunday it's kind of the most
beautiful time of day right now I'm in
New York City and the Sun is setting the
Sun sets so early and it's just gorgeous
so I'm really excited to be here with
you guys oh before you didn't see this
before i started this live stream i like
set dress everything try and make it
look like look like oh well this is all
very professional and now i'm just like
sitting directly in front of all my hard
work um oh yeah my editor just tweeted
else pigs at else pigs on twitter if you
guys want to go follow our and who is my
book out of there cuz hey thinking of
segues that work for what this live
stream is it's about the book um Lauren
actually with the one that asked me she
said you know the books been out for a
little bit maybe let's do a live stream
let's as a need to a live stream to talk
to you guys now that you had a chance to
like spend some time with the book and
let it you know marinate in your brains
and your body to talk to you about your
thoughts on it questions that you have
comments you have um parts of it that
you just completely skipped over because
you knew you'd hate it before you
started no that's not correct hold on
i'm just making sure that everything is
managed properly also what am I I put
these glasses on because I felt like
look this feels very author much author
very
knowledge is what this look is okay yeah
it's happening and you guys are all here
now I think the best way to do this
because I'm oh ok I'm going to click
this and then we turn the volume off of
that yeah now I can see all the comments
yeah oh one comment I just saw I'm so
gay not me they said that they're so gay
cool job Tori that's great self aware
where self-awareness self-awareness is
them a really great quality to have in
your human so I'm happy for you ok um so
yeah I thought it'd be fun to hang out
on the Sunday the Lord's Day and just um
talk about book stuff and get your
thoughts on it I think the easiest way
to do this for me because I am so I'm
just looking at the reflection of the
computer in my own all right there we go
those lasted longer than I thought they
would um I think the easiest way to do
this is to tweet at me at grace Helbig
with the hashtag Grace's guide so I can
go through the hashtag and look for
questions and then I'm also gonna take
some questions from the YouTube comments
that's it that's correct I also guys oh
I won't lie to you i woke up at 145 p.m.
today my body clock is off so I'm
caffeinating myself right now for the
first time today I also reblog last
night that I had a last room then woke
up this morning completely forgetting
that I had initiated this and thank God
I went on tumblr and check because I was
you know at one of those mornings I was
like I can just sit and then and catch
up on everyone's blog mrs. and see
what's going on and then nope I gotta
clean myself because we're gonna be
presenting ourselves to people okay
great um I guess I will I guess I'll
start this haha like there's any other
option would you care to contribute
stone cold you just be read the book
he's still reflecting on all the wisdom
and it's just you know
great uh I guess I will start and say um
that it still hasn't really hit me that
I wrote a book um but it makes me so
excited when I see all of your tweets
and photos and things that you've sent
me via all the social media saying you
either sell the book somewhere or you've
got gift of the book or you are gifting
the book to someone or that it has
affected you or impacted you or any of
those things it's really really really
really cool because you never know you
put words on a piece of paper within
intentions of good with thoughts of
health and hope and when it gets
returned to you in the way that you
really hoped it would it's it's a very
cool feeling and I guess because it's
also like holiday season and we're all
feeling very sentimental and sweet about
everything that it feels extra sweet
right now so first of all I want to say
thank you to everyone out there that is
bought a book or is going to buy a book
here's the thing they make really great
Christmas gifts or other holiday
festivity gift-giving occasions but I'm
just turning the vibrate sound I always
put my phone on vibrate thinking that
that's like the more respectful thing to
do and then the vibrate noise is just as
bad as it's like there was an actual
noise that happened with it so hard of
me for one moment and we're dad dad um
where was I oh yeah oh the lights gonna
be changing look doesn't this look like
I'm in like the most beautiful jail of
all time yeah I know my sentence is like
I got sentenced to the early bird filter
that's what this looks like hey so don't
mind the light changing we'll figure it
out as it goes if it's going to be a
real problem um oh they make Grace's
guide makes fantastic gifts watch this
did it break rock solid all the way
through all the information still there
so can't say that about fine china can
you just smell
so let me go on Twitter and let's start
answering questions because that's why
we're all here I think unless you happen
to get here by accident in which I say
it's okay if you need to go this is not
what you were hoping for okay crisis
guide thanks mom you're welcome here's
the thing i don't even mind getting
called mom anymore as long as you're
buying this book you can call me Mom all
damn day is there any this is from
big-hearted square is there any parts of
your book that you really wish you could
have kept in you could have kept in it
you mean parts of my book that you wish
that got edited out that I could have
kept in here's a funny story so I the
other night got a chance to catch up
with them one of my college best friends
Andy because he lives in New York and
because i'm here i got chance to see him
and his girlfriend and there's some
parts of the book that he's like
mentioned did not by name but he was my
other roommate with michelle for some of
the stories that are in here and there
was a story about his a is like early
days of okcupid dating that really just
was so hilarious to me but not like most
flattering story of him and the girl
that was involved and I at one point had
that in the book and then Lauren um very
gently and delicately told me that maybe
this doesn't reflect well it also is
just a story I kind of like shoehorned
it in in one I don't remember what
section I was trying to put it in but uh
yeah basically a girl faked having it an
STD to him because he was breaking up
with her after they weren't even really
dating she had you know um she had you
know seasonal crazy it comes on in the
winter and the spring and the summer and
the fall um oh I I got the chance to
tell him about that the other night when
we were getting things and it was really
fun and he had completely forgotten that
a lot of that story happen so always
great to remind people of the pain from
the past that's part of the
one of the greatest parts of writing but
look at this like I mean I feel like a
detective's gonna come bursting to that
door and asked me where I was marched
14th 1989 I was busy being four years
old yeah that's where I was okay let's
see some other question hi hi would you
write a second book from WT how big I
would write a second book and might be
some where in the path of doing so can't
say anything else but this was actually
just such a great experience I think
I've said this off chance that I uh you
know making web videos for so long and
doing like live shows and that sort of
thing use a different part of your brain
sit down and write and this was this
although it was stressful and hard to do
at times also felt like a really cool
brain exercise because I got I'm so far
away from writing that I really enjoyed
it I you know they say hindsight is 2020
and like you look back a bit god that
was a really hard time and it was my
hand side is saying but it also was
great I really enjoy writing and so I
want to do it more there's a hey okay
let's see what else do we have going on
uh oh the real KTB said my roommate use
your book for a college speech totes
officially educational I hope she also
used the word totes in her college
speech and I house I hope that the
college speech wasn't about worst books
of all time that are not helpful to your
growth as a human being mm-hmm but
that's really cool some of you have
actually sent me things saying like my I
told my professor about your book or we
talked about in class or and that's very
cool or they're even selling it on your
college campuses which really it's
amazing oh my most favorite tweet that I
got about the book recently that I
reached created the other day was that a
girl found it uh in in the train station
and Airport right next to Mike Tyson's
book and I felt like yeah we I mean yeah
his demo is my demo like we share a very
similar
fan base and I hope that we did some
they collaborate my need for a facial
tattoo is very small if completely
non-existent but that said I would love
to see his facial tattoo in person and I
thought that that was maybe the most
flattering book placement of all the
placements that I've seen so far okay
let's see what else do we have don't
forget guys I did contribute to the
conversation a hashtag races guide on
Twitter for now that's what I'm going
through and then I'll go through some
YouTube comments how are your sunday is
going by the way I hope they're well it
is Sunday correct oh gosh yes okay who
what do we have here uh at who's Ellen
Elin Eaglin when did you get the idea of
writing a book um I've said this before
i'm a really competitive person but not
in a competitive way that's gonna make
anyone feel bad or that like ruins cards
against humanity for everyone involved I
maimry and Hannah both had sold book I
concepts and Hannah had basically
finished writing her book while we were
on the set of camp Takota that I I
really wanted to do that I knew for a
while that I wanted to write a book I
think I mentioned it in the video that
people have found from like two years
ago from like 2012 something like that I
said that I would love to birth a book
and with no real intention to real
thought around it and then when I let
myself you know give yourself some
opportunities and kind of really process
something or think about something or
wrap your brain around it I gave myself
a chance to wrap my brain about around
what kind of book I'd want to write and
this was there it was there in my brain
and I wanted to make it a real thing my
old roommate and really great friend
from college Michelle Vargas who is now
getting more into YouTube videos she's
doing a lot of cover songs which is
really cool so go check out Michelle
Vargas and all but she's doing a lot of
taylor swift covers right now so very
topical also she's got the most goddamn
amazing voice and I'm really happy that
she's like using it and putting it out
there cuz she's always been like she's
one
those like silent karaoke ninjas you
know you don't think of her as a singer
that much and then she'll just get up
there and sing It's Raining Men and you
lose your mind and it's it's really
great so anyway Michelle got it is also
a life coach and got into that world and
we kind of got in that world together a
little bit after we graduated colleges
are working with some people and so the
idea of self-help has been in my brain
for a long time and something that I
thought was um it's just universal it's
like music it's everyone who lives a
life and everyone needs help in some way
and you learn things and the internet is
for sharing and that's what I've learned
I big part of it so I wanted to continue
to share my thoughts on life in a way
that was funny in a different medium so
that was a long-winded way to answer
that question I hope that that was
helpful let's see Oh Manny Zhao said
loving the new hair how you feeling
about it yeah this is all fake guys I
got fake long hair now that I'm feeling
really good about it also feeling like
it's um it takes a lot to take care of
and I'm just waiting for the moment that
these all start falling out publicly in
front of people because that's going to
move really fun to figure out that akit
about dealing with that also there are
dead sunflowers next to me and they
smell so bad screenshot this this is the
cover of my second book I don't owe you
hmm and it's called you smell bad sick
today oh well what it's about no one
knows gotta read it uh let's see what
else do we have here Oh gs3 2793 says
hey I'm going to ramapo in the spring
any advice and you've asked that five
times I guess um oh here's my question
to you guys why the [ __ ] do you ask the
same question on Twitter and then number
it not appealing
go throw that for a round program
opposed where I went to college it's a
small liberal arts college in north
jersey I haven't been back since i
graduated in 2007 so it's been seven
years so i'm sure the college has
changed very much um college is honestly
what you make of it so it's basically
like college as a canvas they provide
you this thing this tool to use and then
you have to paint on the canvas and when
I first went to college I'll be very
honest I hated it I didn't enjoy my
experience I really thought it was going
to be like the best time to reinvent
myself and find out who I wanted to be I
was gonna party like crazy i was gonna
like learn so much about selling a date
a bunch of guys and it was it was
terrifying i did not adjust well at all
and my mom told me to stick it out just
one my after my first half freshman year
I was already applying to other colleges
my mom told me just wait one more
semester before you apply and then
figure it out just do one full year and
I found I found comedy and I found um
interest that I had that I wanted to
pursue I had a job in the area I met a
guy I i just got inspired to do things
that I thought were really cool so you
really if you go to college when you sit
back and you try and let college college
you it's not gonna come it like you
really have to be proactive to get what
you want out of it especially because
college is so goddamn expensive it's
insane when you think about it that you
pay so much money and if you don't
proactively try and do [ __ ] while you're
at college all of that money is
basically like throwing it out of a 35th
floor story window and just letting it
fall to the ground you're gonna end up
the same kind of person unless you
really try so it's not it's cool to try
is what I've learned to is that I know a
lot of people think that that's like
nerdy or stupid but it's actually kind
of cool I don't yeah trying and being
passionate about things or
like really great qualities of a human
being I think at least some of the other
people that don't think that way um
let's see my computer's going a little
slow so i'm updating these flowers are
killing me you guys they smell so bad i
know what i'll do i'll just replace them
with my candle that i have burning as if
you guys were actually gonna be with me
in person i put on deodorant and perfume
and I lit a candle as if you could
understand and you know take on any more
thing oh very beauty guru much life
together says a candle this candle I got
last night is pumpkin and nutmeg apple
and vanilla cinnamon and walnuts whirl
what this candles trying real hard and
you know what like we just said trying
is cool there's three different candles
in one candle eat [ __ ] all other makeup
gurus you think but it smells fantastic
and I've bought it at a grocery store or
less I at midnight on the corner because
I guess sometimes you get a whim of
domestication can't bite it let's see um
spray q8 said hey grace why should i buy
the book and is it worldwide well you I
mean I can't convince you you really
have to look in your own heart and
figure out why you would need this book
but i would say i'm just trying to
showcase off showcase off yep show off
or showcase my interior design skills
some of which you can have if you read
Grace's guide you can buy it is
worldwide it's all over the place I
don't know exactly where it is but just
look for it it's got a pretty obvious
cover uh and it's in a lot of places
also Grace's guidebook calm you can
order it from any website off of that
website it's really easy like it's maybe
the easiest thing to get other than an
STD hey oh you knew that was coming oh
that's what she's had
took a turn it all took a turn uh but
this is a great thing for the holidays
because it seeming like here's the thing
I in the past couple years I would
always buy my family members each a book
that I thought would be that they like
and then I get them like a gift and that
was kind of like they're they're
stocking stuffer gift was a book and
then I get them something else more
personal and you know with no intention
that they were actually going to read
the books just made me look really smart
and cool like buying than the books
however this book you can buy and it
makes you look smart and cool and hip
and young and fresh and clean for giving
it to people but then when they read it
which they can because they can read you
can read even started at any section
like look this is a great chapter you've
already learned so much and then you
don't have to ever go back to that
chapter you don't have to read it in
Nick like in linear form it look fam
dance crotch you just got educated just
by looking at something like that's
bracket yeah that's the emotion here um
no this sir i just i i really like it
and if you like things i like then I
think you might like this there does
that sell it enough for you I hope so is
anyone else getting really hot okay
let's see what else um Oh grace hellz
big what advice would you give to people
who want to write um the advice that I
would give to people that want to write
just goddamn do it sure it's see the
writing is a really actually a big
physical activity you really have to UM
sit down and put time into it and have
like you have to have intentions of a
purpose if that makes sense of like this
is for purpose um making videos is kind
of you know making videos and doing
improv which was my heavy background is
it feels a lot easier writings really
difficult to do it
reply it applies it requires a lot of
discipline um so you just need to do it
and I do at one point I bought you know
the artist's way which is a book that's
mostly full of a lot of activities and
like brain stimulators for people that
are artists they're creatives that want
to get motivated or inspired and I did
some of the things in there and it never
really resonated with me at the time I
was reading it instead I used it prop up
my air conditioning unit in the
apartment that i was living in and then
the air conditioning unit leaked all
over the book and ruined the book and I
thought oh this is like this is a sign
from a deity somewhere I don't really
need this book but one of the exercises
that's in it I think a lot of places is
the stream of consciousness writing
which is what I did where you just word
vomit onto a piece of paper I remember
that was actually it was kind of
terrifying because I from making videos
five days a week for so long everything
I was doing that seems like she would
punch this got published somewhere I got
put up online so it would belt really
weird um to sit down and try and write
things and I just throw it away like it
was like know that I need to use that
that has to be my final work and in the
book it really tells you that every
morning I there's a stretch of time that
it tells you to do it and you write
three pages of nonsense whatever's in
your brain when you wake up and then you
throw it away and that I mean it's also
a lesson in like how much your brain can
create consistently and constantly if
you let it that the fear of like I'm
going to at some point my life run out
of ideas isn't um this kind of helps you
prove that wrong and the funny thing is
and I've said this before about the book
is it all those three pages that you
would throw away normally in that
exercise uh there's the book that's how
I wrote the book really stream of
consciousness which I think works for me
that's the other thing about writing you
need to find your style you need to
figure out where you like writing how
you like writing uh and why you like
writing we
remembering why you like it in the times
when it sucks so much will be the most
helpful thing in the world what else do
we have going on here um grace Helbig
did you consider other names to the book
before settling with Grace's guide yeah
there were a ton of other names for the
book and one of my favorite things that
they did in the book which lauren and
the designer of all the book like the so
what would happen is I we would go back
on email chains like sending along ideas
for the name of the book and then when
Lauren my editor was asking about you
know specific chapter names for the
different sections of the book like your
love life your work life all that social
life whatever um I would send a list of
like here's ten potential names for the
love chapter and then they took that on
these things and they they put all of
the things that I or most of the things
that I had sent them that we're
potential uh names for the chapters and
then this is your social life they art
of talking to other humans but I love
that then we got to use like what would
be like literary bloopers and put them
in the book as all the other names so
yeah there was a ton of names for what
the book who was going to be called um I
don't remember off hand any of them
specifically but I do remember that when
we came up with the art of pertaining to
be a grown-up it took me so long to
remember uh what the title was because I
have such my brain sucks addy it's
really bad for remembering specific
things so when people would ask me after
we officially came up with the title I
would have a huge brain fart somewhat my
book was actually called that's why when
I'm in interviews with people and they
either don't get the name ray or they're
looking in like a cue card with the name
on it or reading it off the book I don't
feel bad at all it's a long title trust
me I get it I get it all I want you
remember is grace this guy's been to but
uh yeah I'm at the art of pretending to
be a grown-up ring so true and I'm so
happy
you that the whole team agreed that that
was a great title for X I think it's I
think it's really just we don't know
we're doing none of us know what the eff
we're doing in life so we're all just
trying to figure out the art of
pretending that's life we're all actors
um okay Oh sniffing Helbig all right
it's a great name how was writing
memories forward if you guys don't know
mamrie Hart my really good friend also
just finished writing her book I think
she's in the final tweaks of it she just
announced she got to finally announce it
with the cover which is goddamn adorable
it's great you guys need to check it out
i think it's already available for
pre-sale which you should also look into
for the holidays even though it comes
out the spring that's okay it's always
great to have like long-term gifts to
look forward to I got to write the
forward to the book which I mean they're
so I've known memory now for nine years
something like that like it no not nine
years no that's wrong six years I think
six maybe seven years something like
that um and the it was really really
really very cool for her to ask me to
write the forward and then it gets
really terrified when you think about
actually having to do it um vegas
there's so much to be said about memory
and there's already so much um the
memory and I have gone through together
that leaves online all right so you
don't want to just repeat all the things
that are already out there in the world
for other people to see so it was it was
really fun and I finished it a couple
weeks ago and send it to her I remember
I wrote it I wrote it a little tipsy on
plane and I remember the guy next to me
I felt like he was reading it over my
shoulder the whole time which was really
a great experience because some of the
things that I was writing were
ridiculous and the moments that she and
I have gone through that are just insane
so um yeah it was it was really fun and
also really stressful because memory
book is basically it's kind of a memoir
but it's done a really unique way
because it's stories of her life
which spoiler alert she is the most
insane stories the most insane like
she's already said her parents can't
read her book I shouldn't they are gonna
learn too much about her and it you here
I've only heard some of the stories and
so their stories in there I'm excited to
read about so I've never heard of uh and
you're like how one how are you live
right now and two I feel like I've been
living under a rock in comparison to
your life you have an insane insane life
but then the unique thing about her book
is that every chapter has original an
original cocktail recipe that's based on
and inspired by the story in that
chapter and which is really really cool
and so writing the foreword was really
intimidating because I knew the whole
book is gonna be like so crazy and so
awesome and fun to read that I wanted to
make a forward that you know set the
tone and felt really fun and let you
know the memories got him crazy and the
best way possible that's why I asked Tim
my brother Rajon botanist follow him on
all social media at rage madness to
write the forward to this and it was
really great and he came back with a
forward that was surprisingly sweeter
than I had anticipated and caught me off
guard by a really wonderful way so um
yeah it it's really fun when you write a
foreword to a book it's like it's crazy
you're just you're setting the tone it's
like you're welcoming everyone to this
party that you're not hosting but you're
trying to give the best first impression
before they get in the Fourier and then
when you call it a Fourier like that
they're like when we came to the wrong
party so okay let's answer some more
questions what do we have yeah okay Oh
meow Georgia says have you considered a
memoir yeah no I can't do it here's the
thing about me um and it's so
interesting because I went into all of
these publisher meetings which is how
you you sell your idea for a book you
said in meetings with a bunch of
different publishers and you pitch them
your idea and I made a huge point to
tell every publisher I'm not writing a
full art forward I'm not writing a
memoir one
because I don't have a ton of crazy
stories in my life I'm pretty a pretty
boring for a lot of it and to any crazy
stories that I do have have already been
put out and into the media entertainment
world in video for more on stage or some
other it wouldn't be knew it wouldn't be
fresh so that's why it was cool to write
a book that wasn't about me but
indirectly is a lot about me I put in a
lot of stories that I didn't realize I
had in my brain and I didn't realize
that i hadn't chaired before so i think
this was kind of the perfect mix of
being able to write a book that is a
that it's not about me cuz that's a lot
of pressure but i also get to write a
book that's a lot about money without it
being that way felicia day just
announced that her book is coming out
which another book you should go check
out and lauren is also the editor on
that book so it's all really exciting
and Felicia has had a crazy history of
life and hers is a memoir and I gots to
have brunch with her a few weeks ago and
asked her about it and you know it's
it's a really it's a weird thing to
write a memoir that's what she said she
said good feels it's so hard to talk to
want to share your story with the world
without feeling so self-serving and
Felicia's definitely a really humble
down to earth human being but she has a
crazy life so I'm really excited to read
her book and they just announced it and
the fake covers up which is so great so
go look at that because it's all really
fun great stuff cool people putting
words on two pages that make inspiring
thoughts for other cool people I'm
getting exhausted just even thinking
about it ah let's see did you do to dude
it uh Sadie k Harrison are there any
other media outlets you'd like to get
into you've got a book a movie what's
next um there's a lot of stuff I want a
camila to finish sentence
sure that's something on the docket um
there's a lot of media outlets I'd like
to get into that I hope I get into that
I Oh we'll see what happens there's a
lot of really cool stuff um I i don't
i'm not big on making like five year
plans tenure plans you know vision
boards any of that sort of thing I just
I kind of try to take ideas and
inspiration and work with people that
make me feel excited about stuff in the
moment when it's happening it's a whole
the whole improv philosophy of saying
yes I think that is so basic but it is
so powerful if you let it exists in your
life in a in a cool way saying yes to
ideas and thoughts you have that you
might be afraid to do but you know could
be really cool to do um can really
change your life and make you a better
human being this is so sincere what the
[ __ ] I think sorry I thought a moment
where I'm like the the Sun is setting
there's a candle burning next to me
there's a Christmas tree in front of me
but like all sudden this got really too
sweet and got to sweet you guys so let's
just all take a second to focus on the
fact that this stuffed dog has arms that
look like penises there we go that
changed the game oh thank god poof cuz
it was gettin it's gettin sweet in here
so everyone keep all your clothes on and
today repressed with all of your
thoughts and feelings yay I was the
original song rap maybe rap is a medium
that i'll have to get into because you
know you never know um let's see uh Kiki
gr for Ace how big how to motivate
yourself Oh motivate yourself is like
the hardest thing i always say that like
two of my most favorite feelings in the
world is laughing like unforced laughter
just like natural belly laughter is the
greatest feeling and then also
inspiration feeling inspired is the best
and those two feelings you can't force
on yourself accusing that's also a great
feeling um but genuine laughter and
inspiration are two things that you
can't force but feel so good when
they're happening so to motivate
yourself I mean on a simple level giving
yourself small goals to work towards is
always really great and then why like
surrounding yourself with people and
things that are really cool to you I've
been watching this is kind of I've been
really really busy all year and this is
finally the time of year that things
have slowed down and I don't have so
much to do there's still a lot to do but
I don't have so much to do so when I
have free time I like I said have been
watching vlogmas videos been watching so
much YouTube right now and I could look
at that and be like I'm wasting my time
watching all of these videos but I see
it as like inspirational stuff i've been
watching so many beauty gurus and i
finally I made a parody beauty nighttime
routine last week and that felt really
great and that came out of just watching
a ton of YouTube videos so i don't see
it as a waste I see it as um
productivity in stimulating my brain
yeah tell your parents that's why you're
watching TV and not doing your homework
you're productively stimulating your
brain best of luck to you with that
argument I feel like it's getting really
um the lightning is getting too intimate
so I'm gonna change it up a little bit
Oh once i get wait ah did that change
anything oh yeah okay very cool guys ah
yeah lots of mucus gonna pick much to
take a second to show you how goddamn
beautiful just stage looks right now
sorry just once I don't even know if
you're gonna be ballistic look what
a favorite time of day when the light
hits the buildings in such a beautiful
goddamn beautiful way sorry i just want
to share that pretty thing with you
because sometimes seeing things in real
life rather than to instagram photos is
really cool even though i just digitally
showed you guys something um so let's
take i'm going to be here till five PM
eastern standard time so we have like a
little over 15 minutes left just to let
you guys know i think there's like three
thousand people watching right now this
is awesome cool job everyone for being
here if you don't know we're here
talking about i wrote a book called
Grace's guide the art of 10 be a grown
up it's a tongue-in-cheek self-help book
about how you too can pretend to be a
grown-up because we're all doing it but
why not do it a little better grace is
guiding book calm if you want to go
order it and it makes a great gift and I
think I was thinking about this the
other day like is this is it mean to
give someone a guide book about life
like does that suggest that you think
that they're not living life correctly
and that they need some help but it's
not it's helpful it comes from a great
place so by this for all of your loved
ones for pets a lot of you have shown me
on tumblr that a lot of your animals
like putting their calls on the book so
that's a that's a great thing I'll take
it I wish it there was like an Amazon
review section where it could just be
photos of your pets with but with
Grace's guide ah sorry that's just a
really great idea okay I'm gonna shelf
that for a second and get back to that
after this let's keep answering your
questions just so you guys know on
twitter if you at me or use the hashtag
Grace's guide um that's where i'm
getting all of the questions from and my
twitter handle is just at grace Helbig
Congrats woot woot um you papi come to
England uh stay tuned
let's see um our blackery how big are
you planning to sell those bottle
pillows i buy the [ __ ] out of that the
thing is this bottle hello it's adorable
like it's got little feet and hands and
it was given to me um I show that memory
and I did recently and it's awesome i
love it so i'm not selling it but it
seems like if you put your mind to it
you could make something like that
another human did it's very cool I
here's the thing too i'm so into cracks
lately uh my friend Jocelyn Hughes if
you guys don't know she's got a web
series called DIY damn it it is the best
thing ever and you need to go look at it
because I have now that I'm in like
Christmas gift buying mode I've been on
etsy like crazy like looking for gifts
that are a little bit more personal a
little bit more thoughtful than just
gift cards and craps you guys they're
great and when you do them well they're
great um but my friend Jocelyn is really
fantastic to get it and she's got a web
series that's really hilarious but also
teaches you how to make crafts so if
you're into that kind of thing DIY damn
it on youtube look up Jocelyn Hughes
she's also just a really wonderfully
sweet great funny person she's a good
quality person the kind of person that
you want to have around you because you
feel like you're a better person just by
osmosis of being close to them um let's
see do-do-do-do-do-do no filter grace if
you had a talk show who would be your
ideal first guest who I don't know no I
get well just ideal guest in general
would be I've done a lot of like
interviewing people and sitting out and
talk good people and it's really scary
to do that because you get nervous about
how you come off towards them and if
they're gonna be perceptive and engaging
and want to have a conversation so I
think any ideal guests for any sort of
having to sit down and have a
conversation type of thing would be just
a human that wants to be there that is
excited
is engaging that listens and provides
conversation I mean this is baby just
describing a great date too that's yeah
I think a great interview guest is like
being on a great date where you just
have a really fun time and it doesn't
feel like you're doing work that but is
that day day I don't know great um let's
look at some more questions MC bin 36
took a 14 hour train ride chicago and
read your entire book loved it thank you
that's awesome it's really easy to read
on trains planes in automobiles if you
are the passenger not the driver but if
you're the driver you know what i have
read the audio version of this book you
can get a gracious guidebook calm and
listen to while you're driving and not
compromise your driving skills and/or
safety hey grace is guidebook calm or
all of your driving and life living
needs oh my brain is full of mucus and
thoughts hmm Holly Phillips X any advice
for people wanting to start on youtube
i'm super-nervous you just have to do it
that's the thing the things that scare
you you should be the most excited about
because there's obviously reason that
they scare you um I have to always
remind myself that when I have something
I need to do I have to do and I'm afraid
of it is that the fear comes from a
place of you care about this thing if
you didn't care about it you would feel
nothing about it so that obviously means
that you should pursue it there's a huge
there's a ton of quotes and improv about
just doing it and facing your fear it
would say follow your fear follow your
fear is it really i mean not into like
the belly of an anaconda whatever the
fact that like discovery channel special
was that happened recently but follow
your fear into things that you think
will make you a better person and just
start making YouTube videos so many
people have and are doing it and so you
can do it too because it takes a while
to figure out one what you want to do on
YouTube and how
to do YouTube it's there's a lot more
that goes into talking to a camera by
yourself than what you think so start
now and allow yourself some time to
figure it out it's like like cooking a
meal just start because it's probably
going to be bad to give yourself some
time to go end up buying take out to
replace the meal that you ruined that
make any sense um it's grace H open the
book to a random page and read it out
loud okay let's do that
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop a bit okay
oh how to get over a hangover this seems
oddly appropriate um if you currently
have a hangover stop reading this right
now trying to read when you're hungover
is only slightly worse then trying to
read when you're sober hashtag loll
hashtag books hashtag irony hashtag stay
in school hashtag unless school isn't
for you I hope hashtags never go out of
style so that this book never feels old
guys cool so I just getting lost in the
words myself right now um let's see what
are the questions do we have um at cath
and [ __ ] okay cath hancock cat Hancock
who knows the word [ __ ] is in your
Twitter oh how was it being there for
Hank green and john green when p4a
reached 1 million if you guys don't know
project for awesome assisting the Hank
and John Green do every year and I got
to be part of their live stream
yesterday which is great because it felt
like a warm up to this live stream and
while I was on their live stream they
surpassed 1 million dollars from
donations and if well it was really cool
to be there I also felt like an awkward
fly on the wall be like this is a real
moment for you guys but I'm here so I'll
take it in as a moment for all of us and
celebrate I love when people have great
moments so it was very cool to be there
for their great moment make you to
project crossing calm and check out the
campaign that's still I think their life
Justin finished earlier today but I know
that the
campaign itself is still active so go
check it out oh okay um w t hell bake
said Kourtney Kardashian just gave birth
that's very exciting um someone sent her
my book as a parting gift seems pretty
good Oh Sadie Harrison how what was it
like narrating your own book it was
really weird this is really [ __ ]
weird now writing my own book I'm you
sit in a booth and you from start to
finish read the book oh I sign this book
I guess to myself keep it up don't stop
ever forever love grace thank you grace
for that words of wisdom for those words
of wisdom um it was weird reading you
read your own book your own words from
start to finish to someone in a booth um
that doesn't really know you and one you
hope that you don't get judged on your
reading abilities that was the one thing
that I overlooked before i got there was
when was the last time i've read
something out loud to someone else like
when I used to go to church growing up I
don't remember it was yeah that was
hilarious thing um I always I'm not a
strong reader I'm going to throw that
out there like swimming not strong at it
but i'm i'm okay i can do it just not
the best like a lot of things in my life
so I i remember in high school and
middle school like never ever wanting to
get called to read out loud um because i
was just afraid of sounding dumb doing
it and then having to sit in a booth for
like five hours on two different days
back-to-back five hours each time just
reading words out loud in words that
I've written so if it didn't make sense
I couldn't blame someone else for like
the sentence structure of this I wrote
it so it was terrifying but it was also
really great to be able to read it the
way I wrote it in my head um a lot of
people have other people read their
audio books and touch tone and Simon &
Schuster really great about
letting me read it in my style and in my
tone and for those of you that have
listened to the audiobook I hope you
really like it I do wish that I had more
fun with it that i was more animated I
think I I had no idea what I was doing
so I'm just trying to get through it so
I'm sure that closer to the end there's
either there's probably just you know
pops of inflection and animation and
then like you can tell when I'm getting
really tired or I remember my voice was
also like really horse so it's drinking
tea like crazy and the audio grants
listing his you know he this is his job
so here's a really sensitive and in tune
to how you sound and I remember him at
moments mean like do you want it do you
want some tea like indirectly telling me
that my voice sounded like [ __ ] so I get
so self-conscious in those moments of
like how I must sound terrible i need
tea i guess uh also hilary duff walked
in and recorded something in the studio
while i was there and i went like this
so i was eating lunch as she walked by
and I was like as if I didn't even know
who she was or wasn't even excited that
she was two feet in front of me and
gorgeous nailed it pretended to be a
grown-up like best I could let's take a
couple more questions we like five
minutes and then I gotta go put food in
my person um mr. peter p who did you
meet that has inspired you the most on
this journey of writing um you know what
I I when Hannah's book came out and she
found out that she got on the New York
Times bestseller list like that was
really inspiring to see because Hannah
her journey on YouTube has been this
like this star seemingly accidental
thing that's turned into like a really
well thought out and really so coolly
branded career path job but she is
always in her heart wanted to be an
author and so she her experience with
her book was really really special to
see she she's cared about it tremendous
and it really meant something to her a
and when she was telling me that I
remember feeling like just so inspired
by just an authentic feeling of really
wanting something working really hard
for it and then getting it and having it
happened because of hard work and
because of a want and it just felt like
oh here the formula seems so simple in
theory you want something you work hard
for it hopefully you get it and it
happened with her and I was so just like
yeah I was so happy and I was so excited
and that really that really helped
motivate especially because I got to see
while we were on the set up camp Takota
I got to see some of her writing process
like we got to memory and I got to toss
around ideas with her and she got to
like read us some stuff and oh do I have
the book right here yes I do my drunk
kitchen a guide to eating drinking and
going with your gut another great
Christmas gift idea for those out there
looking for books or people also it's
hard cover which watch dim Prague at all
can't say that about fine china kenya
and the pictures are hilarious the same
photographer robin shoots at robin
shoots on all social media who did my
book did Hannah's book and I when I saw
Hannah's photos I was like Robin please
come capture my likeness in a camera and
she did and she's fantastic speaking of
like other inspiring amazing artists
people to be around Robin roamer the
photographer is insanely I'm just like
I'm just going to speak so wonderfully
of the people that helped um yeah
Hannah's Hannah was definitely a person
that was really inspiring in the whole
book writing process because she just
had such a genuine authentic care for
writing her book and for hoping for its
success it was just so great my process
was really really fast so I didn't have
that much time to reflect on like how to
like really think about how the book
does when it comes out alright you know
it's just you go
to provo mode and you hope that people
buy it and liked it and watching hannah
like have a real moment about her book
was very excitingly cool ok let's take
like two more questions and then i gotta
go i expel all the mucus from my face um
Grace's guide is trending how does it
make you feel guia court helping GA
makes you feel very great i think i
guess it that's validating isabella
dating yeah yeah sure great um how big
snacks which of your moms quotes from
the book is your favorite uh yeah that
was the goddamn other cool thing about
ratings book is that I got a chance to
showcase my family like my younger
brother Tim wrote the forward and my mom
who growing up she's been a poet her
whole life and she used to make these
things called chat books where she would
write all this poetry and she would get
a pouch of payroll money to get these
little books published of all of her
poetry that she try and sell them at
like craft fairs and that sort of thing
he always never to make a profit it was
just too hope that someone reads it and
feels something positive about it and I
remember not really even like thinking
about if I remember like helping her
design them and never like I know that
now looking back oh my god she made so
many of these chat BOTS it was really
really cool and so when I reach out
there and and I wanted her to put
something in the book and I asked her
for these words of wisdom I had no idea
one she returned them so quickly and to
thing is we were under such a deadline
to get the book to end that I didn't
even get a chance to really read them I
just sent them straight on to my editor
instead like here who's this add this in
and it wasn't until I was recording the
audio book in the booth that I read my
mom's for the wisdom out loud for the
first time and so I think that there's
probably a couple of recordings that he
got deleted from the audiobook of me
going like mom's words of wisdoms don't
sit under an orange tree waiting for
apples to grow mom
like real moments of reading things out
loud and being so like wonderfully
pleasantly surprised and like whoa my
mom is really goddamn smart that's
really it's great and yeah it's here's
some others ok I'll leave you with some
mom's words of wisdom cuz I'm gonna head
out in a second um the two most
important gifts to bring to any party
tolerance and acceptance yeah alcohol
tolerance and acceptance that you're
gonna have a hangover the next day heyo
that's not what she meant mom's words of
wisdom I love cooking especially when
someone else does it you wonder where I
get my comedy you guys this thing birth
me mom's words of wisdom the right job
for you should say yes to these three
questions does it make you happy most of
the time no one loves a job all the time
can you make a decent living from it are
you helping others in some capacity if
you can answer yes to all three then
this is your job how appropriate to end
the five stream on this because this is
part of my job and I say yes to the
dress all three of those make me very
happy i hope that they're helping this
book helps you in some way that makes
you happy and i love this job it's
really great thank you guys for joining
me on this live stream i'm gonna head
out um you know i'm gonna head out with
a shot with you guys will you join me
and everyone get it a beverage get a
beverage yeah right I'm really gonna
manage oh then I'm getting one don't
worry and come with mucus okay we're
gonna end this live stream for Grace's
guide I'm Grace's guy book calm on a
toast okay great cheers everyone hold up
glasses we're all internet frontier dad
I hope that the people that live on the
other side of this apartment have heard
Lee in this whole time oh um cheers to
you guys thank you for buying the book
reading the book uh putting it on your
to-do list to get or to give to others
and this has been really really cool and
cheers miss the end of 2014 I hope that
you guys have had
really great years and that I hope that
you all felt inspired to do something
really [ __ ] cool in 2015 hey want to
make a win America pinky swear that
we're all gonna do something really
[ __ ] cool in 2015 let's tell you
pinky swear right is that working yeah
there we did it cheers guys thank you
for bo I just spilled it god damn it it
doesn't smell it's all over my hand
great Cheers ah that's the sound of an
adult I'll see you on the internet guys
sleep